me gusta partir de la premisa de que
todos los seres humanos podemos mejorar
nuestra propia calidad de vida que me
refiero con mejorar nuestra propia
calidad de vida absolutamente todos los
que estamos aquí podemos hacer
cualquiera de estas cosas y mejoras en
nuestra área podemos mejorar de manera
personal salud física financiera mental
espiritual hay diferentes nd maneras en
las que podemos crecer y avanzar
entonces todo está adicto a esta charla
se trata desde esta premisa por ende
para mí eso es el liderazgo el liderazgo
radica en crecer y expandir tu vida y a
la vez expandir la de otros impactando
la de ellos creo que el liderazgo tiene
una correlación directa con la
abundancia entre más impacto tu
generación la gente mucho más abundante
eres por así decirlo tres formas raras
porque tres formas raras porque cuando
yo ida me adentré en este proceso de
adentrarme a conocerme y hacia adentro
que yo le llamo también me tocó estar en
el proceso de mucha gente y ver a
muchísima gente en este proceso aprendí
que el proceso de trabajar contigo y
estéreo invisible e intangible no es
para nada lineal no tiene una línea no
no es predecible por eso le puse raras
porque a veces pareciera que son fuera
de lo común entonces el primer punto que
quiero explicarte es cierra las llaves
ya que me refiero con cierra la llave te
tengo que contar una historia una vez
estaba en mi casa a punto de meterme a
bañar en una ducha de agua y estaba yo a
punto relajarme porque había sido un día
de trabajo largo y antes de meterme a
bañar recibí una llamada de un gran
amigo mío que su novia le había
cancelado ahí el concierto de uno de mis
artistas favoritos entonces me hable
meses ama tenemos un boleto más para ti
y este boleto es baby y tiene backstage
6 que 20
yo me al me dice pero sólo tenemos una
condición la condición es que tenemos
que pasar por ti en cinco minutos porque
ya está por iniciar
yo emocionadísimo me muevo me arreglo
bien rápido y entonces pasan por mí me
voy al concierto y ese día era todo
espectacular toda la fiesta la música mi
artista las butacas a canciones y el
backstage todo era increíble pero qué
fue lo que pasó estando en el concierto
en el pleno apogeo recibo veo en mi
teléfono y había un montón de llamadas y
eran mi vecina sookie que es un que
estaba bien preocupada porque me hablaba
para decirme que mi casa se estaba
inundando
olvidé apagar cerrar la llave de la
bañera de mi casa pero hace una pregunta
ustedes creen que yo podría disfrutar el
concierto en ese momento sabiendo que en
mi casa se estaban inundando muchísimas
de mis cosas personales
mi mente se fue del concierto y
únicamente estaba pensando inundaban la
preocupación de qué iba a pasar con mi
casa y también arruinándole un poco la
noche a mi amigo que yo ya me quería ir
porque utilizó esta metáfora porque la
mayoría de nosotros no nos damos cuenta
que tenemos un montón de llaves abiertas
en nuestra vida que no nos permiten
estar completamente presentes incluso en
este momento todo aquello que nos quita
la energía de este precioso momento es
una fuga o es una llave que tú tienes
abierta te quiero dar algunos ejemplos
porque puede haber muchos está resentido
con alguien es una llave abierta estar
enojado con un ex amigo tuyo amigo
pareja padre madre amigos socios ex
socios es que dante o como le quieran
llamar y tú estás pensando eso está
quitando energía de deber o que te deban
dinero también puede ser una fuga y una
llave abierta estar en ambas partes y
tercero hasta un fallecimiento
porque sé por qué pasan estas fugas o
estas llaves que dejamos abiertas que
nos quitan energía básicamente suceden
porque hay una represión de un
sentimiento que quiero que te imagines
una pelota que metes debajo del agua y
la pelota lo único que quiere cuando
está bajo el agua es salir por así
decirlo pero nosotros estamos ahí
manipulando reprimiendo un montón de
sentimientos y emociones porque a veces
socialmente no está bien visto comunicar
las o expresarlas esto nos lleva a
sentir diferentes emociones como
resentimiento culpa miedo vergüenza
orgullo ego y esto lo único que hace es
frenar frenar nos muchísimo en nuestra
vida por la cantidad de energía que nos
quitan ahora aquí viene lo más
interesante que una vez el doctor
leonardo iglesias que es una persona que
quiere tome terapia que fue director de
la facultad de medicina el autónoma
nuevo león me hizo una pregunta
espectacular y me decía tú crees que las
llaves que tú tienes abiertas no son
notorias para los demás y es que tengo
algo muy algo que decirles que no les va
a gustar pero les va a servir y esto es
que tengo que decirles
es notorio la cantidad de llaves que
ustedes tienen abiertas en su vida para
su círculo cercano que ustedes no la
quieran ver es otro rollo pero son
notorias así es que aquí viene mi primer
tip en esta forma rara la forma rara que
yo propongo frente a esta sociedad es
que comuniques de manera responsable los
sentimientos y experiencias que tú
tienes y qué vivencias y que sientes esa
sería la forma número uno de crear el
liderazgo punto número 2 hace una
extraordinaria tubería por eso decía
raras todos van a decir cómo tiene
extraordinaria tubería pues mira a mí me
gusta usar un ejemplo quiero que te
imagines y que una tubería la tubería
básicamente funciona es muy simple
funciona así hay una entrada del agua y
hay una salida del agua este es el flujo
y este es el propósito de la tubería
nada más para eso sirven para darle
flujo a un cierto líquido que queremos
que vaya hacia algún lugar bueno pues
quiero que te imagines que esta tubería
nos representa a nosotros y que el flujo
en vez del agua representa la vida misma
representa lo siguiente
que tenemos habilidades que tenemos o la
vida misma dinero pareja experiencia que
tenemos en el amor gratitud y todo esto
hay un gran amigo que también me ha
enseñado mucho que se llama gabriel nos
hobbits y él decía él es muy amigo del
doctor miguel ruiz el doctor miguel ruiz
es el autor del libro los cuatro
acuerdos ellos son muy amigos y me
platicaba que una vez estaban en
teotihuacán y tuvieron una charla sobre
la abundancia y él y ellos sostenían lo
siguiente sostenían que la abundancia
radicaba en una danza entre dos cosas
entre la generosidad y entre la gratitud
en el punto donde estas se forman donde
se conectan ese punto era la abundancia
entonces me sonaba increíble y ellos
decían entre más generoso seas y entre
más de entre más de eso aunque te duela
mucho más abundancia generas en tu vida
pero a la misma vez entre más agradecido
seas
más abundancia tienes en tu vida yo ese
agua está espectacular este este nuevo
concepto pero a la vez se me venían
varias dudas porque entonces yo a veces
no siento abundancia y porque a veces no
soy tan generoso como sé que podría ser
y es que y ahí me di cuenta de algo que
es lo que pasa se acuerdan que les dije
que hay que cerrar las llaves quiero
retomar ese punto y traerlo aquí de
nuevo quiero abrir una y imagínense que
no cierran las llaves que ustedes no
comunican los sentimientos que tiene
pongamos un ejemplo hay un ejemplo un
matrimonio joven ya los días uno de los
dos pues el hombre la mujer se da cuenta
que el otro le está siendo infiel y
entonces llegó un día y entre anp ante
el celular de su pareja por por lo que
sea y ve mensajes con otra persona
entonces yo le llamo a esto que algo
ocurre en nuestra vida algo pasa en
nuestra vida algo ocurre y a partir de
estos sucesos sucesos relevantes que
tenemos en nuestra vida lo que nosotros
hacemos para no sentir porque no
queremos sentir el dolor que nos rompan
sentirnos vulnerables expuestos
chiquitos pisados lo que hacemos
instantáneamente como un mes defensa es
contarnos un cuento contarnos un cuento
sería tomar una decisión que para
nosotros se vuelve una realidad por
ejemplo si fue la mujer la que puso el
cuerno el hombre diría algo como las
mujeres son unas mentirosas ya entendí
las mujeres son así y las mujeres pues
decir o los hombres son unos mentirosos
ya entendí esto es así la vida es así y
entonces todo lo que vamos creyendo
también se va creando en el día a día me
interesa mucho la flecha que viene ahora
de la historia y el cuento de la manda
de nuevo para acá eso lo que quiere
decir es que quiero abrir una
posibilidad de una pregunta que puede
ser una posibilidad no será también que
con nuestras creencias percepciones y
formas que vemos el mundo también vamos
creando eventos
para nosotros validar nuestras propias
ideas y creencias y es que creo que los
seres humanos somos adictivos a tener la
razón aunque tener la razón sea como
ponernos una soga en el cuello y
entonces se acuerdan que les dijo en la
tubería volvamos a la tubería cuando
nosotros nos cerramos las llaves en
nuestra vida lo que empieza a ocurrir es
que el medio del tubería ocurre algo
horrible y es que se empieza a llenar de
piedras la tubería y la tubería deja de
funcionar para lo que funcionaba para el
flujo de la vida para el flujo del agua
y entonces la tubería ya no funciona
porque ya es muy poco el chorro que sale
y entonces esas esas bolitas negras que
ven ahí son las piedras son las
creencias los cuentos que ustedes y que
nosotros nos hemos ido contando que
dijimos que eran una verdad absoluta
para nosotros según por lo que nosotros
vivimos
y esto entonces es cuando estamos en la
relación con alguien o en el trabajo y
sentimos que está apagado que es
monótono que es frío sentimos
resentimiento contra esa pareja contra
nuestro jefe contra nuestro amigo con
nuestra mamá porque estás bloqueado es
un bloqueo entonces tengo un tipo una
guía que es para salir de esto es súper
importante que te abras a una
posibilidad solo es una posibilidad john
está diciendo que es una verdad
solamente digo oye y si a lo mejor no
todas las mujeres son mentirosas una
posibilidad oye y si no todos los
hombres tampoco son mentirosos qué
pasaría si te verías una posibilidad de
hecho creo fervientemente que los seres
humanos por estar encerrados en nuestras
ideas nos perdemos de una infinita
capacidad de muchísimas posibilidades la
vida radica en todas las posibilidades
que no te has cuestionado que no te has
preguntado por qué no te has abierto a
la posibilidad porque dentro de ti hay
algo que quiere tener razón todavía
porque está resentido enojado cerrado o
con miedo y el tercer paso se llama wu
wei
esto es una filosofía china creo que
esta o esta pero el weight si ustedes
incluso lo pueden buscar en google
significa no hacer o no ponerle esfuerzo
algo es lo que significa rendirte y va a
decir como que rendirte todo te va a
contar una historia muy breve había un
rey que era avaricioso y que habían
logrado todo era rico poderoso dinero
tenía todo pero entró a su avaricia él
decía yo quiero más yo quiero más ahora
que se me antoja si ya tengo todo dijo
ya sé lo que se me antoja ahora quiero
ser sabio y entonces woods reunión sus
consejeros y le dijo chicos quiero ser
sabio y entonces que me recomiendan para
ser sabio y entonces los más eligen
bueno allá en la montaña en la punta hay
unos monjes que te pueden enseñar a ser
sabio entonces el rey agarró su caballo
se dirigió a la casa del sabio con la
puerta y el sabio abrió la puerta el
hijo que quieres dice rey sabio ley del
rey vengo a darte el privilegio de que
me hagas sabio y entonces él sabe dices
bueno tú eres un tonto lárgate de aquí
le cierra la puerta y el rey dice no
tienes idea quién acabas de correr no
sabes quién soy no tienes idea de lo que
voy a hacer más toda destruir toda esta
casilla simple que tienes y entonces el
sabio no le abre más pero entonces va al
rey y al reírse dice ya entendí y no me
pueden ganar tan rápido el sabio lo que
quería era probar mi humildad claro no
lo había probado y regrese a tocar la
puerta y le dice al sabio sabio ya
entendí tú lo que querías era que yo
mostrara mi humildad claro esa no me la
esperaba es muy buena brillante entonces
él sabe de qué prueba estás hablando
lárgate me casé no creo que él vuelva a
cerrar la puerta
el rey dice ves te dije el mentiroso por
claro porque lo único que te importa es
sólo cierto el sabio eres un vende humo
no se queje entonces el sabio se queda
dentro y el rey no quería regresar
porque los consejeros le iban a decir
como regresaste tú él todas las puedo se
queda pensando y regresa con el sabio y
toca la puerta de nuevo y le dice sabio
hago lo que quieras por favor enséñame
hago lo que quieras y el sabio le dice
el rey ok paz lo que ya seguros y ponte
a barrer todo el camino que llega a mi
casa y entonces el rey lo que es que
dice triste lo que sea y se pueden
agarrar la escoba y empieza a hacer
barre con mucho con mucha energía y
entonces acaba de barrer el camino
limpio y regresa con el sabio y le dice
ya está barrido el camino que al que
sigue ya me vas a entrenar y el sabio le
dice no estás listo vete de aquí y
entonces el rey al irse se queda
pensando afuera y agarra la escoba y
vuelve a barrer y vuelve a barrer y pasa
otro día y vuelve a barrer y vuelve a
barrer y pasó todavía vuelve pasan
varios días
ya los días el que él barría y tenía
impecable el camino barriga y barriga
barriga y barriga va a arribar ya cuando
pasan los días el sabio un día abre la
puerta y le dice rey estás listo te voy
a enseñar cuando el sabio le pregunta
qué fue lo más importante que aprendiste
al rey el rey después de la importancia
de barrer por barrer y eso es wu wei wei
significa que todo lo que hacemos tiene
que tener tres principios tiene que ser
genuino tiene que ser natural y tiene
que ser sin ninguna expectativa
simplemente como dice también john
lennon let it be o dejarlo ser dejar que
sea simplemente ser una forma natural de
hacer las cosas sin forzarlas sin
ninguna manipulación ni absolutamente
nada de eso pero cuál es el problema que
muchísimas veces nosotros actuamos como
el rey y entonces empezamos la dieta
empezamos el ejercicio salimos con
alguien y queremos que ya esté el
resultado y si no nos enojamos y nos
vamos allá trabaje una semana en mi
empresa si no me suben me voy
entonces no estás en google según los
chinos los chinos dicen que el huawei es
como una flor una flor no hace un
esfuerzo por abrirse una flor florece
porque su naturaleza florecer
entonces la gran pregunta es aquí porque
estamos a veces esforzándonos demasiado
para que no reconozcan nos valoren
obtener ciertos resultados en nuestra
vida entonces el punto número 3 es
eliminar cualquier expectativa detrás
del acto que estás haciendo y siente
gozo alegría y gratitud por el simple
placer de hacerlo eso sería google
quiero aclarar tres puntos nada más
deseo de todo corazón que todos los que
están aquí los que están viendo esta
charla tengan la posibilidad de tres
cosas importantes uno cerrar todas las
llaves que te tengan a desconectado
porque tú las puedes cerrar cuando
quieras punto número dos y punto número
dos que seas una tubería extraordinaria
que seas extremadamente generoso y
extremadamente agradecido y la tercera
si haces eso quiero recordarte algo que
a lo mejor se te había olvidado estás
destinado a florecer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]